foreign
[Music]
box today we are checking out the new
GeForce RTX 4060 TI though I should
specify that we're covering the eight
gigabyte version not the 16 gigabyte
model that's Now set to arrive in July
and really that should be the only model
but I think this well I think the 16
gigabyte version I'll talk about this
more later in the video maybe may have
been a bit of an afterthought certainly
a lot of you agree that that was the
case based on a poll that we've done but
I mean speaking to that there's no real
indication here that uh well first of
all these are eight gigabyte graphics
cards and that's going to make it
difficult when you're trying to well
when you're just looking at the box and
trying to work out is this the eight
gigabyte version or the 16 gigabyte
version so there is a small little eight
gigabyte label on the side of this box
but on the front uh yeah I can't see one
unless I'm missing it and certainly
can't see one here either so probably
that does suggest that maybe the 16
gigabyte version was a bit of an
afterthought and a reaction to all of of
your push back against these eight
gigabyte graphics cards in 2023 anyway I
think an eight gigabyte graphics card
for 400 US is complete and utter garbage
it is laughably bad so strap yourself in
as we rip nvidia's new RTX 4060 TI a new
one but before we do today's sponsor
spot is brought to you by skytech Gaming
a provider of pre-built gaming PCs in
California they offer lifetime technical
support backed by well-trained customer
support and all their systems feature a
one-year Parts warranty one of their
newest pre-built is the Azure 2 which
skytech gaming sent over for us to check
out this is a well put together PC that
looks great the boss has been tuned for
optimal Cooling and noise performance
and the cable management is extremely
neat it features the new GeForce RTX
4070 along with the core i5 3600k and
this allows it to deliver impressive
mid-range performance while supporting
all the latest and greatest features
such as DLS S3 frame generation Ray
tracing and V1 encoding so to get the
right PC built for you check out the
link in the video description
okay so for now I can refer to this
graphics card simply as the 4060 TI but
in not too distant future we will have
to identify if we're talking about and
testing the 4060 TI eight gigabyte or
4060 TI 16 gigabytes so that is going to
be a lot of fun now I'm not going to
bore you with the full rundown of all
the specifications as we've already
covered all that information last week
in Tim's RTX 4060 series announcement
video so I'm going to assume that if you
care about all of that stuff you've
already watched Tim's video or you're
willing to go back and check it out
there really is quite a lot to discuss
here namely V or M capacity and I will
get into that in Greater detail towards
the end of the video we'll have a look
at some examples and just discuss that
but obviously this is a major problem
with the RTX 4060ti as it only packs
eight gigabytes of vram and yeah Nvidia
still think they can charge 400 us and
yeah there will be a 16 gigabyte model
but it's set to cost even more at 500 us
which is problematic in on itself
frankly we don't really even need to
test the RTX 4060 TI 8 gigabyte to tell
you it's a disgustingly poor value
product and just a horribly
disappointing release from Nvidia in
short Nvidia is claiming RTX 3070 light
performance for a hundred dollar
discount which would be great if they
solved the most glaring issue with the
RTX 3070 in modern games and that of
course being its very limited vram
buffer I can't really be clear enough on
this point there should only be a single
RTX 4060 TI and it should have 16
gigabytes of vram just no Exceptions
there oh and it certainly shouldn't cost
500 us at most 400 us for a 16 gigabyte
version of the 4060 TI I think that's
probably acceptable
sadly though Nvidia has missed the Mark
here by at least 100 U.S anyway keeping
that in mind let's go over the Benchmark
data check out some cost per frame stuff
and then we will form our conclusion for
testing the CPUs there's the ryzen 7
7800 X 3D which has been paired with the
gigabyte x670 aorus Master with 32
gigabytes of ddr5 6000 cell 30 memory
I've tested at 1080P 1440p and 4K though
we will of course focus on the 1080P and
1440p data for this reviewers those are
more realistic use cases for this eight
gigabyte GPU all of this data is fresh
and updated for this review so let's get
into it
okay first up we have fortnite using the
more optimal DirectX 11 mode but the
visual quality settings have been maxed
out which ideally isn't hagged play even
in a semi-competitive setting but since
we're testing GPU performance I think
the Epic settings make sense at 1080p
the 4060 TI rendered 130 FPS making it
just six percent faster than the 3060 TI
which I have to say is super
disappointing and that meant it was
three percent slower than the RTX 3070
the 1440p data is even more
disappointing here the 4062 I only
managed to match the 3060 2i making it
12 slower than the 3070 and I believe
the issue here is the narrow 128 bit
wide memory bus whereas the 3060 TI has
a 256 bit wide bus resulting a 56
increase in memory bandwidth Nvidia does
claim that the larger L2 cache boosts
the 4062i's effective bandwidth to 554
gigabytes per second which is a 24
increase over the 3060 TI but we're
certainly not seeing evidence of that
here as the 4060 TI certainly looks to
be memory bandwidth Limited
next up we have Resident Evil 4 and the
1080p results do look more promising
using the prioritized Graphics quality
preset which doesn't enable Ray tracing
here the 4062i was good for 135 FPS so
that's a five percent boost over the RTX
3070 and then 14 over the 3062i so
that's certainly a better result but 14
over the 3062i at the same price with
the same vram capacity it doesn't
exactly have me jumping out of my seat
then as we increase the resolution of
1440p the 4060 TI can only match the
3070 though it was still 14 faster than
the 3060 TI but again it's not exactly
amazing progress after two years or so
a plague Tower Requiem has more mediocre
performance for us at 1080p here the
4060 TI managed 91 FPS making it a few
frames slower than the 3070 and just six
percent faster than the 3060 2i then as
we've already seen a few times now that
larger L2 cache really isn't making up
for the much narrower memory bus as
Nvidia claims I'm sure it does help but
not enough at 1440p is here the 4060 TI
only managed to match the old 3060 TI
which I'm sure I don't have to tell you
is a super disappointing and even
depressing result
f122 does enable Ray tracing by default
using the ultra high preset and as I've
said a number of times in the past this
halves performance and just isn't worth
the visual upgrade but that's just my
opinion anyway we've tested the game
using the default settings and here we
found that the 4060 TI is just a few
frames faster than the RTX 3070 and
worse still just eight percent faster
than the 3060 ti so it's unlikely that
Ray tracing performance will be more
impressive relative to those similarly
priced to previous generation GeForce
parts
and then we see the 4040p margins
they're much the same here at six
percent faster than the 30 17 11 faster
than the 3060 ti so I guess decent
performance overall but also seriously
underwhelming at the 400 US price point
in mid 2023. next up we have cyberpunk
2077 with more of the same the 4062i
roughly matched the RTX 3070 it was
slightly slower and it did provide just
single digit gains over the 3060 TI also
as we've typically come to expect at
this point the 4060 TI does perform
worse at 1440p at least relative to
those previous generation gpus it
performed closer to the 3060 TI than it
did the 3070 which again is just an
awful result
Dying Light 2 sees the 4060 TI
delivering RTX 3070 light performance at
1080p with 101 FPS so a 10 boost over
the 3060 TI but again as we increase the
resolution to 1440p the 4060 TI becomes
more like a 3060 TI offering a mere
three percent performance increase so
basically an indistinguishable
difference here
watchdog's Legion appears to be sort of
a best case result for the 4060 2i
allowing it to outperform the 3070 by 5
margin at 1080P and that meant it was 15
faster than the 3060 TI which seems
decent based on what we've seen so far
but really it's not then at 1440p the
4062 I can only match the 3070 making it
just 11 faster than the 3060 TI
actually I think Forza Horizon 5 looks
to be a best case result as here the
4062i was 11 faster than the 30 70 and
23 faster than the 3060 TI which
realistically I think should probably be
a minimum increase but sadly that's
certainly not the case then at 1440p the
margins once again come down now it is
just seven percent faster than the 3070
and 18 faster than the 3062i which is
hardly cause for celebration the total
war Warhammer 3 results at 1080p Well
they suck to put it bluntly as here the
4060 TI was only six percent faster the
3060 TI making it four percent slower
than the RTX 3070 then at 1440p we are
looking at 3060 TI performance so Nvidia
is really going to be working pretty
hard to sell you on the frame generation
technology as there's really not much
else on offer here
the Spider-Man remaster results are as
you'd expect really more of the same the
1080p results see the 4060 TI come in a
few frames slower than the 3070 and just
six percent faster than the 30 60 TI
then at 1440p it's just four percent
fast and the 3060 ti so basically the
same level of performance for the same
price with the same amount of vrams so
that's just awesome
Hogwarts Legacy is very heavy on memory
bandwidth even without Ray tracing
enabled and this is a problem for the
4060 TI and it meant at 1080p it trailed
the 3060 TI by a five percent margin and
the 3070 by a 12 margin of course things
only got worse at 1440p I see the 4060
TI was 11 slower to the 3060 TI and 14
slow in the 3070 it even lost out to the
6700 XT
the Halo infinite results were better
but even so at 1080p we're only looking
at 30 70 light performance for a small
15 bump over the 3060 TI it did maintain
that margin at 1440p suggesting that
Halo isn't particularly memory balance
sensitive but still RTX 3070 light
performance isn't amazing given the
price and specifications
here we have the results based on the
latest version of The Last of Us Part
One which addresses vram usage and while
it does improve the situation it still
highlights the limitations of pairing
high-end graphics cards or what a
relatively high-end graphics cards with
just eight gigabytes of vram even at
1080p we're seeing worse one percent low
results on the 8 gigabyte models and
this has impacted the 4060 TI but it's
at 1440p with the ultra settings that
completely the 8 gigabyte cards
and this of course includes the 4060 ti
so that is certainly a concern not just
for what we're seeing here but for
future games and sure you could lower
the texture quality settings but the
fact that we can quite clearly
demonstrate a vram limitation under
playable conditions is unprecedented for
a new GPU review and it will surely
spell disaster for future AAA games
and moving on to Call of Duty Modern
Warfare 2 we find that the 4060 charge
is good for 121 FPS at 1080p making it
nine percent faster than the RTX 3070
and 21 faster than the 36 DTI so a half
decent gain there this time now as we
increase the resolution the margins do
remain much the same and this sees the
4062i 8 fast and the 30 70 and 20 faster
than the 3060 TI
finally we have Hitman 3 and here we're
looking at RTX 3070 light performance at
1440p with 140 FPS on average so an 11
Boost from the 3060 TI then we find much
the same at 1440p 11 over the 3060 TI to
match the 3070 so more underwhelming
performance
now just quickly here's a look at power
consumption or total system power
consumption with the 46 DTI and it did
push total system usage to 273 watts in
Hitman 3 which is a good result given it
matched the performance of the RTX 3070
allowing for an almost 30 reduction in
total system usage the 4060 TI also sat
between the 3060 TI and 3070 in
Spider-Man remastered and at push total
system usage to 255 Watts which is a 33
reduction when compared to the 3070. so
it is certainly a very efficient GPU
okay so here's a quick look at the
average performance scene across the 15
games tested starting with the 1080p
data as you would have guessed based on
what we just saw the 4062i is basically
an RTX 3070 at least at 1080p making it
just eight percent faster than the 6700
XT and nine percent faster than the 3060
TI then at 1440p it slips just behind
the RTX 3070 basically sitting between
it and the RTX 3060 TI but we're talking
about just a five percent boost over the
3062 which is obviously a terrible
result for the new 4060 TI
then finally just for reference sake
here's the 4K numbers on average the
4060 TI was good for just 38 FPS
suggesting that it's not really cut out
for 4K gaming at least not without
heavily dialed down quality settings
okay so first we're going to take a look
at the suggested retail pricing and
please relax we will get to typical
retail pricing in a moment I just find
it useful to analyze msrps as well and
we see when doing so the 4062i is
technically the best value product of
this Roundup but it's also still
massively underwhelming at 1440p which I
believe to be a more suitable resolution
for this cost analysis given that we are
talking about a 400 US product the 4060
TI improves upon the 3060 charge value
by a mere two and a half percent the
3060 TI arrived during December of 2020
so it is a two and a half yard price at
this stage and what this means is after
two and a half years Nvidia has moved
the needle forward in terms of cost per
frame by five percent that's it and
we're still you're getting the same
amount of vrm so they're relying
entirely on improved efficiency av1
encoding and DLS S3 frame generation to
sell you on a 40 60 TI and that's simply
not going to cut it at least not for
those of you with a 30 60 or 30 60 2i
but of course the picture gets much
worse when we look at current retail
pricing so let's go do that
yeah look this is pretty brutal brutally
poor value for game as that is there's
basically no reason to buy the 4060 TI
it is effectively Dead on Arrival at
least four hundred dollars and really if
you wanted this level of performance you
could have achieved it for less money
anytime over the past six to 12 months
with products like the Radeon RX 6700 XT
admittedly though there's not much here
from Nvidia that competes but again if
you manage to buy an RTX 3060 TI two two
and a half years ago at the MSRP which I
suppose very few people did given the
cryptocurrency boom but if you did you'd
be sitting here scratching your head
wondering why the 4060 TI even exists
frankly if you want to buy or need to
buy a graphics card right now the 6700
XT looks to be a much better deal at
least while stock lasts not only is it
13 cheaper and just five percent slower
on average but it packs an extra four
gigabytes of vram ensuring that vram
capacity won't be an issue for a much
longer period of time it's also not
great for NVIDIA that the 6950 XT offers
slightly better price to Performance
with twice as much vrm so that's pretty
crazy to see there from the previous
generation Flagship but again those
prices are well they've been discounted
and there will be limited time only
deals until stock dries up which I think
for the 6950 XT it's probably not that
far away
now for those of you wondering here's
what we believe the 40 60 TI should cost
or at least the absolute maximum price
in video should be charging for this
product so 300 U.S at this price it
would be almost a 20 discount from the
6700 XT which does have more vram and an
almost 30 improvement over the 3060 TI
which is a more typical and I'd say
expected generational Improvement sadly
though this just it's not the case and
that means you absolutely shouldn't buy
an RTX 4060 TI for 400 US
okay so given how efficient the RTX
4062i is you won't be surprised to learn
the little Founders Edition card is very
cool and quiet maxing out with a diet
temperature of just 62 degrees at a fan
speed of 1500 RPM which does sound quite
fast but the card itself was extremely
quiet and could barely be heard over our
case fans which are already very quiet
to begin with so when it comes to the
design and operation of nvidia's
foundation model we have no complaints
that said though for an even cooler and
quieter experience the MSI gaming X Trio
version of the RTX 4060 TI would be the
way to go this model peaked just 53
degrees after an hour of stress testing
and despite that the fans were spinning
at just 1100 RPM which is remarkable and
of course msi's gaming extra is a much
larger graphics card with a huge
heatsink and triple fan cooler attached
to a very small PCB I do like how MSI
has gone with a single 8-pin power
connector though this just makes a lot
more sense for lowering average cards in
my opinion
okay so here's the latest version of The
Last of Us Part One at 1440p using the
ultra quality preset and as you can see
frame Time Performance frame time
consistency not very good on the RTX
4060 TI performance is all over the
place here a lot of stuttering and
really bad one percent lows which is
what you saw in the graphs earlier on
now if we enable dlss that seems to
mitigate these stuttering issues we saw
due to the lack of vram earlier there is
the odd small frame hitch here and there
in the scene that we're testing but I
would say performance overall is
satisfactory but of course this may not
be true for all areas of the game this
is only a very short test
now previously Resident Evil 4 would
crash when using the maximum quality
settings on an 8 gigabyte graphics card
but that's no longer the case however we
are again seeing horrible frame
stuttering this has seen quite
consistently throughout the area of the
game that we test with so again you'll
be seeing one percent lows that are very
low and again a lot of frame stuttering
now the Callisto protocol could be quite
a difficult game for benchmarkers to
find the vram issues because for the
most part you can run a series of
Benchmark passes and not actually exceed
the vram buffer as it does take quite a
while to build up well not not an
excessive amount of time around a minute
which is generally how long most
benchmarks run for but for the majority
of that Benchmark past the frame Time
Performance could be quite good like
what we're seeing here and here we are
playing at just 1080p so low resolution
though we are using the ultra quality
settings but they're quality settings
that you could probably expect to use in
a game that's already been released on a
brand new 400 US graphics card and yeah
we do have Ray tracing enabled but again
if you're buying a new GeForce GPU
especially if you're paying 400 you
probably want to be able to enable Ray
tracing in pre-existing games especially
at 1080P and we're doing that here and
performance seems pretty good you know
not the best frame time graph I've ever
seen but it's not terrible at least not
yet and now you can start to see some
pretty horrible frame stuttering kick in
the one percent lows are diving it's
bringing the average frame rate down as
well and then yeah the game just
completely well it doesn't crash but
well you've got one percent loads of
almost single digits at this point just
horrific frame stuttering and of course
the game is now unplayable so you're not
gonna be playing this game on any eight
gigabyte graphics card using these
quality settings at 1080p which is very
disappointing obviously
now if we lower the quality settings too
high remaining at 1080p with Ray tracing
enabled the game's pretty playable a
frame time graph probably isn't as
smooth as you'd like to see on a new 400
graphics card but it is playable so you
only have to dial down the quality
setting one notch to get playable
performance
now a plague Tower Requiem 1080p Ultra
with rt enabled and we've seen this game
can be playable on gpus with similar
performance to the 4060 TI but with only
eight gigabytes of vram that's just not
happening basically unplayable here
we've got single digit one percent lows
with less than 20 FPS on average once we
run out of vram which happens almost
instantly and as I got to this section
of the game coming up right about here
yep I thought the game had actually
crashed because that can happen when you
exceed the very buffer but no it was
just having a break bit of a rest and
yeah now we'll uh move on to test with
the higher quality settings and I
thought that this was actually going to
work so the frame time graph again not
perfect but certainly a lot better again
1080p high quality settings Ray tracing
enabled and the game's very playable
we're going up around 70 FPS at this
point and I thought this would work just
fine but then I got to here and quite a
huge frame starter for perhaps that was
just a one-off so I continued doing a
bit more testing but unfortunately no
that wasn't a one-off the game it
basically isn't stable under these test
conditions which you'll get another
glimpse of that in a moment just walking
up here
and I think I pause for a second to look
around now from memory up and there you
go another huge frame starter and then
another one again so they'll just
continue there's not quite enough eram
now this is interesting for spoken using
the ultra high quality settings which do
enable playable frame rates on something
like an RTX 4060 TI we find that the
game doesn't suffer from well
performance related issues there's no
stuttering at least the section of the
game I tested frame rates are quite good
the problem is the game just looks like
crap textures aren't loading and I found
this interesting they've updated the
game whereas the textures didn't load at
all previously they now seem to swap
from areas so if I look up and then look
down you can see the floor textures are
terrible and then they improve and
sometimes they pop in and out which is
what we saw in Hogwarts Legacy again I'm
not going to bother covering here but if
I look at the ground the texture is
eventually load in and it looks
reasonably good this is a sort of a dull
looking area of the game so visually it
looks a bit off but you can see the
ground there has rendered correctly but
anyway this is one of the issues you can
run into when you don't have enough vram
games just look off and speaking of
which we'll move on to Halo infinite
using the ultra quality these settings
at various resolutions so if I turn the
resolution right down you can see the
shrub here this little Bush it's loaded
with a bit more detail The Rock has now
I believe that's the correct resolution
for the rock the trees don't look quite
right but they're certainly better now
if we go back into the settings increase
the resolution up to 1080p we see that
the shrub still looks pretty low
resolution it's obviously not going to
improve as we increase the vram
requirements you see the tree there
still looks pretty awful the rock is
still loading I believe in with the
correct textures but then if we increase
the resolution again up to say 1440 peel
thereabouts
with the little resolution scalar we see
that the shrub looks okay there well it
looks like how it looked not okay but it
looked the same as obviously at the low
resolutions but if we walk away from it
and come back you can see now it's
struggling to fill all the textures in
the Rock texture looks worse the trees
now have lost detail and are just sort
of more of a blurry mess so basically
eight gigabytes of RAM is just not
enough for this game
so there you have it as far as buying
advice goes as I've already said
absolutely do not buy this thing for 400
us it is laughably bad at that price
look if it had 16 gigabytes if you're
around for 400 us and I think it would
be okay let me know what you think about
that in the comments of course but yeah
I don't think it'd be amazing but not
unbelievably horrible either as I've
just shown 300 us is the absolute
maximum amount of money Nvidia should be
able to charge for an eight gigabyte RTX
4060 TI and the 16 gigabyte version
which should be the only version in my
opinion well that should cost at most
350 us but I could probably get on board
at around 400 us and certainly let me
know what you think about those prices
for a 16 gigabyte version of this
graphics card and it seems pretty clear
to me though I should preface this by
saying that this is pure speculation on
my behalf but it does appear as though
Nvidia never really intended to release
a 16 gigabyte version of the RTX 4060 TI
which might explain why it's been
delayed by a few months I'd say late
last year whenever video was working out
the GeForce 40 series product they only
had plans for an 8 gigabyte 4062i class
product for around 400 us though the
pricing would have been penciled in much
more recently but my point is I believe
the intention was to only arm the 4060
series with eight gigabytes of vram
which makes sense given the 4070 Series
has 12 gigabytes but with a number of
recently released games causing issues
for eight gigabyte cards such as the rcx
3070 and we of course have dedicated
videos to pointing this out and the
Enthusiast crowd has pushed back against
nvidia's apparent stubbornness to give
Gamers more vram in video or Force to
rethink plans just as they did last year
with the what they called unlaunching of
the 12 gigabyte 4080 which eventually
became the 4070 TI anyway as I said this
is pure speculation on my behalf and of
course in video will never let us know
the truth but ultimately it doesn't
really matter in the end they're doing
their absolute best to push overpriced a
gigabyte gpus on Gamers and we here at
Harvard unboxed are simply not going to
stand for it now a week prior to this
review we had a private briefing with
Nvidia and as expected the topic of vram
did come up Nvidia employees tried to
justify why the 4062i has an 8 gigabyte
vram buffer at 400 us and they also
tried to explain why this doesn't
actually matter and they did this well
simultaneously speaking of the
advantages of the 16 gigabyte model
which doesn't really make sense but I do
feel for the Nvidia employees trying to
justify these products that can't be an
easy job given the recent evidence of
high-end 8 gigabyte gpus kind of crap in
the bed but nvidia's primary arguments
seem to be that most Gamers have an 8
gigabyte graphics card and therefore
game developers have to cater to them
they can't simply leave them majority of
Gamers behind or their game is destined
to flop this is the same argument I've
seen a lot of Nvidia fans make and I'll
be perfectly blunt it's an absolutely
crap argument and for NVIDIA fans it's
certainly not one that any gamer should
actually make firstly yeah it's true the
majority of Gamers do use an eight
gigabyte graphics card as evident by the
steam Hardware survey and really that's
not a surprising statistic but it does
highlight a major problem that's been
largely caused by Nvidia and to some
extent AMD Nvidia is basically admitting
that they've been holding back the
market with mainstream eight gigabyte
graphics cards for far too long causing
headaches for developers and limiting
the progress of game development it's
also a crap argument because we've heard
from a number of game developers now who
have said they're fed up with these vram
limitations and future AAA titles based
on new game engines will be moving
forward to take advantage of 16 gigabyte
20 gigabyte and larger frame buffers
when using Ultra quality settings
relegating any GPU with an 8 gigabyte
buffer to 1080p medium or possibly even
low quality settings
so those games are still going to work
on an RTX 4060 TI you just won't be
getting anywhere near a premium PC
experience rather you'll probably end up
with an inferior visual experience to
that of a modern console which is a
truly depressing thought for those of
you faced with having to spend 400 us on
an RTX 4060 TI
in the end we had quite a lengthy
discussion with the Nvidia employees
essentially they claimed that eight
gigabytes of vram is mostly fine for
1080p gaming and I should probably
emphasize that nvidia's positioning the
4060 TI eight gigabyte graphics card as
a 1080p gaming product which we find
absurd at the 400 price point in any
case they did claim that it's mostly
fine but also admitted that in some
instances it will be a compromised
experience that will require Gamers to
dial down certain quality settings which
again we find unacceptable at 1080p
given the price it was also a bit of an
odd discussion where nvidia's employees
claimed that eight gigabytes is fine for
the RTX 4060 TI but also believed that
spending a hundred dollars US more for
the exact same GPU with 16 gigabytes of
memory was a good idea I guess they're
admitting that the 8 gigabyte version is
gimped limiting it to a mostly okay
1080p experience in today's games but
for gamers who wish to enjoy the RTX
4060 TI without memory limitations so
gaming at 1440p for example spending a
hundred dollars more for that privilege
is also fine they're also hesitant to
answer our questions about future games
and speak to the longevity of eight
gigabyte gpus such as the RTX 4060 TI
basically they admitted that vram
requirements will continue to increase
and that 8 gigabyte 4062 owners will
just have to be prepared to dial down
quality settings in the future where
need be and this is something that could
also be avoided by spending a hundred
dollars more on the 16 gigabyte model of
course there's really no other way to
answer that question without inevitably
shooting yourself in the foot obviously
game development will continue to
progress and like smaller vram
capacities that came before it eight
gigabytes will become obsolete at some
point and while that day is likely still
some time away it's clearly going the
way of the dodo at the high end anyway I
think the point that's really worth
hitting home here is that never before
have we reviewed a brand new current
generation GPU especially a mid-range
GPU and have been able to highlight so
many scenarios which should be playable
had the product been given enough vram
and clearly this is a big problem for
the 8 gigabyte RTX 4060 TI and it's 400
US asking price
finally we're not going to dive into
detailed Ray tracing performance for
this review and there's a few reasons
for this firstly the card doesn't really
have enough vram for acceptable RT
performance and we highly doubt support
for future AAA titles is going to be
acceptable at least for some of them
also performance really won't be that
different to the RTX 3060 TI and RTX
3070 so if you're familiar with their RT
performance you'll be up to speed with
what the 4062i is capable of there I'll
probably look more at RT performance for
this product when we get a Radeon
competitor as that comparison will make
a lot more sense then we have dlss3
frame generation a feature in video has
heavily pushed on reviewers for this
generation especially with the 4060
series suggesting that we focus on that
feature for our reviews now as I've
noted in the past a big issue with DLS
F3 benchmarks is reporting frame
generation as an FPS metric as 120 FPS
for example using dlss3 frame generation
really isn't 120 PS it's the smoothness
of 120 FPS with the input of roughly
half that frame rate with the potential
for a few graphical issues and this is
really a serious issue for those
benchmarking with frame generation
enabled and displaying that data on
graphs for example and we suggest any
reviewer benchmarking with frame
generation enabled should report those
numbers as something like 120 dlss 3.0
FPS something that makes it very clear
that they're well they're generated
frames and not rendered frames that
include input and for this reason we're
just not going to show DLS S3 results
that way as it's best thought of as a
smoothing technology not necessarily an
FPS booster as technically that's not
exactly what it's doing also frame
generation doesn't solve vram issues so
it's not going to solve the performance
related issues we found with this
graphics card and that's going to end
what's turned out to be an excessively
long review of a product we strongly
recommend you don't purchase at least
not for 400 us maybe 300 but certainly
not 400 and as I've noted in previous
vrm related content the goal here is to
inform Gamers and raise awareness
hopefully forcing a video to give you
more vram and that will allow game
developers to make better looking games
and I think the 16 gigabyte RTX 4060ti
has some evidence that this is working
so keep letting Nvidia and AMD know that
you're no longer going to stand for
overpriced eight gigabyte graphics cards
and perhaps the GeForce 50 Series won't
suck and that is going to do it for this
review hopefully you guys appreciated
this content enjoyed the video it was a
lot of work and yeah obviously we're
getting a lot of pushback and hate for
our stance on eight gigabyte graphics
cards especially you know high-end cards
I think we've tried to make that clear
that we're not saying all like gigabyte
cards are obsolete or that all graphics
cards need more than eight gigabytes of
air but I think when you're spending 400
yeah and then 500 is a bit of an insult
to get 16 gigabytes
not sure what a video we're thinking
there and based on feedback we've seen
from you guys not well received so
basically our stance is to really no one
should oppose our stance uh anyone
outside of Say in video and AMD I think
we should be on the same page that eight
gigabytes is now holding back game
development holding back the progress of
the gaming industry we want PC to be the
the superior platform really don't we we
want it to you buy these high-end
graphics cards you want them to look a
lot better than consoles you you want it
to be a really premium experience
especially when you're paying a premium
anyway I won't go on about that I'm sure
this will come up many more times in Q a
series and stuff like that but it's a
bit frustrating to see quite a few
people defending
30 70 tis and probably this product as
well it really should have had 16
gigabytes of vram and of course the 4070
series should have had more memory as
well anyway
enough of that that sort of topic for
now I'm just going to move on or I'm
just going to try to move on uh yeah
videos over don't buy it wait for prices
to drop uh hopefully they do
I'm your host Steve see you next time
[Music]
foreign